The Economist
in 1947 Britain prepared to end nearly a
century of rule over the Indian
subcontinent and its 390 million people
Hindus were concentrated in central and
southern India Muslims in Bengal in the
northwest a British Commission divided
the territory into majority Muslim
Pakistan and majority Hindu India in the
chaos that followed partitioned 15
million people fled across the new
borders and 500,000 died in rioting for
border regions saw the worst of it
Sindh Bengal Punjab and Jammu and
Kashmir among India's 565 princely
states only Jammu and Kashmir had a
Hindu Maharajah ruling over a majority
Muslim population India claimed the
Maharaja decided to join India Pakistan
disputed this in October pushed tunes
from Pakistan's Northwest Frontier
Province invaded Kashmir with the
support of Pakistan's government in
October of 1947 the Maharaja left
Srinagar Indian troops were airlifted in
but were ill-prepared for the cold and
altitude Pakistan responded with its own
campaign and India approached the United
Nations to broker a ceasefire which went
into effect on January 1st 1949
establishing a line of control but no
final border in 1962 China attacked
India in the oxide chin region of
Kashmir easily defeating India's poorly
equipped Himalayan troops China retains
control of the oxide Chin today three
years later encouraged by China's
success Pakistan sent troops across the
line of control dressed as Kashmiri
locals the fighting proved brief and
inconclusive on September 22nd both
sides agreed to a un-backed ceasefire
another brief war broke out over East
Pakistan in 1971 this one conclusive
East Pakistan seceded ten million
refugees streamed into West Bengal and
with India's help Bangladesh was born in
1999 after both India and Pakistan had
successfully tested nuclear weapons
full-scale war was barely avoided when
Pakistan tried to seize the cargill
region of indian-controlled Kashmir at
one time an average of one Pakistani
soldier every four days and one Indian
soldier every other day died at the chn
glacier and the terrorist attacks in
Mumbai in November 2008 were reportedly
planned by senior members of
lashkar-e-taiba
which Pakistan created a fight Indian
domination of Kashmir and which India
accuses of terrorist atrocities all over
India the conflict simmers in 2007 777
people were killed in violence in Jammu
and Kashmir bringing the two decade
total above 47,000 by India's official
count according to some cash marries the
total is twice that number